Alexandria, Hilltop, The Kingdom. Our communities have something in common.
we all serve the saviors
we already started this, and we're gonna win
whatever it takes
together, we can beat them
we set thing right, the time is now.
join us, in fighting them.
the walking dead returns this february, only on AMC
well, we find the right stuff, maybe we don't need the numbers
blow 'em up, burn 'em to the ground
you said there weren't just soldiers with the saviors. There were workers there too.
people didn't have a choice
yeah, we gotta win
we need more hands, another group. Negan has outposts.
the geography, the distance works against us
we gotta get back, they come lookin' for Daryl. We need to be there.
you don't have to get back
not yet
it's one of theirs, long range
we can listen in, keep track of them.
so if we're not going back, what are we doing?
I think it's time I introduce you to Ezekiel
King Ezekiel
King?!
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie
so new walking dead footage let's
break it down.
March the war all out war also address what's
going on with Chandler Riggs and Carl Grimes
with the time jump in season eight and all
that craziness.
So there is a new round of The Walking Dead
giveaway that's going on now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the off-season,
so start with the footage first then I'll
address what's going on with Chandler Riggs
relationship with The Walking Dead people
it's not as dire as it sounds, but schedule
didn't say explicitly in any the promos The
Walking Dead is coming back February 12.
So you can see from these two clips were like
two promos jammed together is that everybody's
coming together but we have to convince Ezekiel
to get on board.
So Jesus is going to introduce them.
Rick and the survivors are to have some fun
kissing the ring in meeting Shiva.
So most of the footage is just dedicated to
survivors going to the kingdom which is probably
were going to loop Carol back and eventually
she had this big kick in episode eight about
everyone leaving her alone.
I don't have anything to do with this the
lady doth protest too much she just bring
the kingdom in not understanding I didn't
want you I think one Ezekiel or more in common
here and I don't want anything to do with
your lives to be left alone.
People will die.
A lot of meaning that shall come back eventually
to even if she does stay in the kingdom she
will end up helping them somehow the other
wildcard in the situation is that you know
you have all these people coming together
so you would think oh okay wow, this is gonna
be pretty easy to do though just get a bunch
of help though technique and down no if we
learn anything from people coming together
on The Walking Dead 10 standoffs between villains
and heroes, like in the season for mid season
finale with the governor in his tank some
wildcard always breaks rank goes off plan
it everything blows up in everyone's faces,
so they kind of teased the survivors seeing
a version of what we've seen the kingdom do
when they treat with the saviors the last
time we saw the scene.
Richard almost got in a fight with one of
the saviors.
So even though he was able to keep his cool
remember all those scenes in episode eight
where he started to lose his mind trying to
get Morgan and Carol to convince Ezekiel to
commit to a first strike against Negan and
then he went off and cried in his little trailer
in the woods a lot of your probably like why
they dedicating so much time to him crying
in the woods by himself in this weird trailer
is a big character but why we spending so
much time with them.
So it seems like what they're doing is they're
setting him up is the wildcard on the survivors
the kingdom side.
So if there's any big 10 standoffs if somebody's
going to go rogue.
It's going to be Richard who wants to do the
first strike the other big wildcard is Gregory
at hilltop who is the biggest bag of Dick's
that they have inside one of these places
now that Spencer is dead Spencer was a giant
back addicts Gregory is a giant back addicts.
So there under threat of anybody turning against
them with hopes of bigamy beginning favorable
treatment or securing his leadership, it's
Gregory running to bake Neegan or Grand Theft
Auto.
Trevor however you want to think about him
trying to tell them what the survivors are
trying to do other meeting with the kingdom
they're trying to rally force against you.
Just remember Richard and Benjamin are wildcards
Gregory is a huge wildcard we also see Grand
Theft Auto Trevor come back looking like he's
going to be in some sort of Grand Theft Auto
scene with Rick here driving down the road
that is gonna make so many people happy and
then think about the Benjamin character we
haven't seen him in a while but they spent
a lot of time setting him up is like this
innocent young character that Ezekiel was
trying to watch over because it sounds like
he felt guilty that he got his father killed,
so we kind of took it on himself to take Benjamin
under his wing.
Sort of like a really nice version of what
you kinda saw happening with Neegan and Carl
like Neegan was fascinated by Carl it was
this really twisted psychotic thing so get
Benjamin very innocent character.
Not a great soldier probably close to the
top of my list for characters that are gonna
die in the back half of the season just because
there teasing this crazy intensity.
This build up to all out war and he is just
not a warrior at all, and what happens on
The Walking Dead when the shit hits the fan,
usually the people that get killed are the
innocent bystanders like Olivia and episode
eight and then we gotta talk about just like
this crazy walker that Rick turns around to
see here.
It looks like some Guillermo Del Toro nightmare
just spiked sticking out all over it.
So let me note.
Do you think that somebody dressed a walker
up like this after the fact or it was a human
with some armor on it then died and fell on
a bunch of spikes you can wonder how this
could occur naturally, but I do like the way
they try to create new walkers each new season
like anytime there's a premier or a finale,
they usually try to have a couple really cool
Walker traps in just a couple really bad ass
looking walkers let me know what you guys
think about this promo what you most excited
about when the show comes back know everybody's
thinking about March the war was can end up
happening at the end of the season are they
going to do all out war there still so much
knee can story to be done even if you don't
read the comics.
They are kind of telegraphing things here
like they're coming together but in no way
is this going to go smoothly like is that
there's always a wildcard somebody always
goes Rogue and it all goes to shed and blows
up in everyone's faces.
That is why the season for mid season finale
season for episode eight is still one of my
favorite midseason finale's on The Walking
Dead ever, just because the governor rolls
up with the tank.
Rick tries to get him to chill, but the governor
is in having it the heads Herschel and it
all starts to blow up in their faces and goodbye
prison.
It was one of the best ways that they got
rid of their old said give them a reason to
go somewhere else.
So they haven't really said how much longer
the gonna stay at the safe, so they could
stay there for a lot longer, but supposedly
there's gonna be a time jump when we get the
season eight.
So hopefully the blow up a couple more big
places by the end of the season so moving
onto Chandler Riggs Carl Grimes, what the
hell is going on there.
But all these rumors about him leaving the
show to go to college.
So what's happening in real life is that the
actor Chandler Riggs is ended his seven year
contract that he signed when he first came
on The Walking Dead, so his father posted
the celebratory notice like yeah you know
seven year contract up her so happy about
this accomplishment were so proud of your
bigger and better things on the horizon is
making it sound like he was moving on from
the show and was just gonna go do other things
that people like Carl Grimes is like a really
freaking huge character how they can address
this is this a spoiler.
So the Internet went crazy.
He deleted that post and then Chandler Riggs
is well as his mother came out and just said
this was just meant to celebrate the seven
year contract being completed Riggs said that
he was excited to go to college and was hoping
that he would continue his relationship with
The Walking Dead people, so it sounds like
the continue to do Carl stuff it in a diminished
capacity which I think everybody is fine,
with like if they're not gonna do a lot of
Carl story.
It's okay if he's not standing in every single
frame in the background just to be there,
so Chandler Riggs the actors just really excited
to do real kid stuff go to college hang out
with his friends play video games, but he
doesn't want to stop doing The Walking Dead,
just because of time constraints just expect
them to use less Carl in season eight much
less Carl in the time jump.
They did say there be a time jump from the
end of season seven to the beginning of season
eight.
They didn't say how much time would pass,
they just kind of fueled a lot of the coral
craziness because it like does that mean they
need to recast a version of Carl there definitely
can have to recast Judith, but I think it
just the making a beeline for whisperers,
in the wake of all out war but I do think
that all out war.
Just because it's such a big comic book arc
is gonna encompass the last little bit of
season seven in the early part of season eight
like it is gonna be this long drawn out craziness
then they can make room for the whispers to
come on so is gonna be happening tonight is
I'll post a new flash and then I'll be posting
a Star Wars Obi-Wan Kenobi video before we
get started with Rogue one craziness and I
will be doing a bunch of Rogue one videos
later this week.
So make sure you go see the movie when you
have the chance while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for all my walking
dead videos and you can click here to rewatch
the Spider-Man trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you guys tonight!